we got this story this one luke just
mentioned uh undercover cops
order food then arrest bar owner for
defying nyc
indoor dining rules look at this smug
disgusting despicable man cuomo
he literally killed six thousand people
by putting sick covet patients in
nursing homes
he is in my opinion a murderer who set
policies forth
that they should have known that i can't
imagine they didn't know at the very
least
fine i'll tone it down a little bit he's
responsible for the negligent homicide
of six thousand elderly folks
by putting covet patients in these
buildings now what is he doing his
police
oath breakers new york police officers
arrested a bar owner for violating
covert restrictions after
executing a sting in which they ordered
food from the restaurant ap
reported the new york city sheriff's
deputies entered mack's public house in
staten island new york and ordered 40
of the food and beverages according to a
sheriff's office press release
congratulations guys
you got them selling that food that's
contraband in new york city
the sheriff's officers are wannabe cops
mark fonte a lawyer who represents the
bar
told the staten island advance this is
what happens when little people get a
little power
each one of them will have to answer to
a federal judge oath
breakers praetorian guard for
unconstitutional edict that was never
passed
at a certain point the state legislators
stopped saying we're gonna pass laws and
it's all relatively recent
check this one out this is probably the
most insane thing i've seen in a long
time did you hear this
cuomo signs bill banning the sale of
confederate flags on new york state
grounds
and other hate symbols clearly
admittedly according to cuomo in
violation of the first amendment
probably new york's constitution as well
doesn't care they just do it
and do the police care nah so you know
what at this point
look i moved out of these places you got
antifa setting up their autonomous zones
quite literally don't care have it have
at it bro i don't care
and and i'll tell you this yeah i'll
take it give them new york when we saw
these riots
i was very much like dude defunding an
abosition the place is stupid you know
why
because you need in a civilized society
and this is like a lot of intellectual
dark webs this is brett weinstein said
police need to be able to make arrests
someone is going to commit a crime and
we need a system by which they can
reasonably identify somebody arrest them
and bring them in
and so we have these laws it makes sense
i am not an anarchist luke maybe you
disagree
michael malus disagrees but i think
police
aside from a lot of the the dumb stuff
you know quotas fines or whatever
we need to be able to call a cop and say
you are the essential first layer of
defense for when a crime is committed i
report it to you as an official
you know arbiter you're neutral you're
not you know you know in many cases
then it goes to the courts the da's and
that's the process we have i respect
that in a lot of ways
but right now i don't care anymore i
left these places
because these cops have no no allegiance
to the law to the constitution
they are criminals at this point well
beyond my tolerance level
let me just say one more thing when when
michael mouse was on the show and he
mentioned
that in new york city we have a
constitutional right to bear arms but
these cops don't let him
they are criminals and for me that's not
my threshold i see his point you know
what i kind of agree with him now
now when i see this stuff the cops are
arresting a dude for selling food
these people are despotic they are
psychopaths
and you know what man i i just if if if
if i was given the powers of the emperor
i'd be like those officers badges
removed pensions revoked
exile away gone you are a criminal as
far as i can tell i won't lock them up
but get out of here
well tim one thing you have to
understand these police officers are
political
they're not apolitical they're very
political when they're following through
on these decrees that haven't even been
officially passed by the kind of rule of
law that everyone accepts everyone to go
by
there's even official case law where the
new york city police department argued
that they don't have to do anything they
don't have to help anyone
during a moment that was you felt like
you you interviewed the guy
yeah the cops like watched a do get
stabbed
yes there was a mass murderer running
around joe luzito
a guy who looked very similar to you i
don't know if you know about the story
of joe lozito
amazing human being this random guy
starts trying to kill people on the
subway he intervenes
he gets stabbed up he takes him down the
police officers are literally standing
there right next to him watching him as
he's getting stabbed in his skull with a
huge
butcher knife right then as he's subdued
by joe as the police officers are
literally
watching the whole time this whole
interrocation with guns
with batons not doing anything literally
they take joe off put the suspect in
handcuffs
and they wait there for a long time joe
wakes up in the hospital
almost lost his life was an inch away
from losing his life because of the
blood loss because of the time it took
the nypd to figure out what was going on
the train was in the middle of the
tracks and they took him
a very long time to get them to the next
track to get joe into an ambulance he
wakes up and he has
the mayor there congratulating these
police officers who are deemed heroes of
who who saved the the innocent people
and they called
joe an innocent person joe took the nypd
to court
one for libel calling him a victim when
he's the one that took down the purple
with
the knife as the police officers were
literally standing there
and the new york city police department
argued and one successfully
that they had no duty to help serve or
protect anyone
and that's the case law on the books
right now that the police officers don't
have to do or abide by any kind of uh
decree to do anything for you you know
what they
they these city cops lost all of my
support
all of it you know it was bad enough
when when i called out the the 27 cops
who
were guarding the black lives matter
mural it was illegally painted
in it basically seized taxpayer dollars
to paint a
political slogan to send a message to
trump which was just
insane and irresponsible and these cops
gleefully defended what was clearly
illegal they don't care they're breaking
their oath
and i said of those cops take their
pension away strip them of
everything and kick them out take their
badges and i want to see them
look you're done you're gone get out at
this point
i don't live in these cities okay i left
i was in the philly suburbs
it was actually a fairly nice place we
had our local department was really
really nice
and uh we're now essentially like nearly
to the point where officially moved away
and i was like it's insane to say defund
the police because
most police departments are not big city
police departments
big city police departments are big
massive with huge budgets like new
york's was like six billion dollars
but most departments are not and so you
got to make sure you differentiate
between
what the left is saying when they say
defund the police well they're talking
specifically about
the big city cops right they're talking
about the places where they vote for
these people
these mayors they vote for these these
politicians these these uh
representatives and these governors
and then these cops get appointed so
your beef is where you live
and you know what i realized i was like
you know what's a really good point why
do i care a fancy sense of autonomous
zone
i'm not going to go there i don't live
there and the people who live there vote
for the politicians and the da's who
allow it to happen
they must like it so far be it from me
to tell them the way they should live
if they voted for it and it's being
allowed
more power to you auntie [ __ ]
congratulations on your autonomous own
don't you're not going to see any
resistance for me and i'll tell you this
the cops who are there
and are fighting with them i think those
cops are in the wrong
you you can't allow this to happen the
da's
the people vote for it and the cops try
and go and shut it down nah at this
point
if you and oregon want as an officer are
going to shut down these businesses
by edict and and you know violate the
rights of individuals
then why should i care if the people say
this is allowed if the d.a says they're
allowed to do it then so
what if someone set up an autonomous
zone in your backyard
that's different you call it cops uh in
my backyard right now yeah
on private property property probably
not where we are ian and
and the laws of this current location i
think if someone came onto my property
they'd
i would not call the police if it were
yeah they're probably
in trouble 99 you might shoot them to
death but you know ideally you'd call
the cops because they're
someone's coming on private property so
that's what those people if bro we're in
the middle of nowhere it's pitch black
outside if people are looking on my
property they're going to be in serious
trouble
it's it's not like look uh when i lived
on a farm in miami
we the only the only weapon we had was a
22 break barrel
uh pellet rifle because like we were not
gun people at the time especially me it
was like fun we were just like shooting
targets in the backyard
and one day someone jumped the six-foot
fence surrounding our property on a
five-acre plot
and there's you call the cops
congratulations they'll be here in 40
minutes
so what do we do well maybe it's not the
smartest thing to have done
but i broke the barrel and and dry fired
it
bang and the person with the light ran
back the way they came
gone if i called the police they would
have said
do you have a gun well then what do you
want us to do we can't we can't get
there for 40 minutes 40 minutes
you know like where we are right now
like how long it would take no no no
that's why we are armed
and that's why i'm like i'm i'm i'm out
of philly i'm responsible for myself
if someone in philly one of the property
you know one of my properties are doing
something i'd call the cops and the cops
would
in most instances promptly remove them
and that's why i think
you know i'm not blanket defund the
police because
that's something they'll do they'll
resolve the issue when a guy tried
breaking into my other house
the cops showed up literally in like one
minute it was amazing
and the cop said to me if it was me i
would answer the door the shotgun
and i'm like bro we're in new jersey
it's not that easy
it's not that it's not that hard but you
know i have sympathy for the cops i talk
to a lot of cops in dc i've got a lot of
sources inside mpd and they are always
constantly telling me
how opposed they are to mayor bowser
how opposed they are to the black lives
matter stuff on the street how opposed
they are
to the uh sort of rules of engagement
that they have and the restrictions that
are put on them and
and how difficult it is to check out
riot gear and like
all these things that make it even just
harder for them to do their job harder
for them to be safe
etc there's a constant conflict there so
and and the guys that staff the dc
bro what are they doing hold on hold on
hold on i hear you i hear you
the moment they go in undercover and
arrest a guy for serving food is the
moment i say
buh-bye i don't care what happens in
your city you guys
are are attacking innocent people at
this point
you you are harassing you are degrading
and berating and insulting
and destroying the lives of regular
people who are not hurting anybody
so you know what you're on your own but
i don't care what newspaper that's just
a couple of guys
that could have been just a couple of
you know angry
jerks then i want to see then i want to
see all of the nypd
calling in a blue flu and saying this
crossed the line we won't enforce it
and they won't do that they won't stand
back while riots happen they'll have the
little slow down
as of course riots are hitting fifth
avenue and they won't do anything then
which they did
uh and leaving people helpless as of
course people are just literally running
down the street taking whatever they
want that's literally what happened
there was police officers during riots
in new york city that were on the same
block just standing by
kicking rocks not doing anything fox
news was there two o'clock in the
morning filming them be like i don't
know what's going on
this huge shock on this fox news
reporter's face
i can't believe the cops are just
standing there and these guys are just
running into all these stores and taking
whatever they
what do you think was going to happen
they did nothing yes during the riots
exactly and then the moment cuomo says
by decree
that your life is destroyed the police
went with
pleasure yeah we're going to go i'm
going
to
stick up for my dc mpd guys i think it's
different in new york
you know just that's just the vibe that
i get from the cops in dc and what i
have
that's what i observe on the street and
as a citizen in dc and that's what i was
trying to say just a moment ago
like i'm not going to blanket my small
town cops outside of the philly area
because they were really awesome they
did a great job but when you look at new
york city
why should i care yeah they defunded the
cops a billion dollars
good i don't care these cops they they
they go under cover and
sting a bar for serving food but what
about during the riots
terrible yeah just the worst possible
and and so i look at
i look at portland and they got this new
you know
red house autonomous zone they're like
booby traps and stuff and i'm just like
you know what
at this point why should i support any
of these guys in these cities they
locked down oregon
they shut down these businesses and when
the riots were going on
many of the cops when they were told not
to interact with the federal police they
said okay
they're like we wish we could help bro
you're a human being you can make a
choice
nothing's stopping you from making a
choice imagine if like
you look at any comic book hero look at
the you know the marvel
movie civil war imagine if the heroes
were all like oh gosh darn it they told
us we couldn't go and fight the bad guy
oh well and they just didn't
you know you bring up a good point with
your with your joke
it does take a superhero to resist
to say no to a direct order to maybe
perhaps
violate what who knows what they believe
the law is what their education level is
on these decrees versus
legislation whatever it takes a hero to
stand
alone in a circumstance like i'm not
saying it justifies
doing the sting listen listen i'm just
saying like it does take especially
we should be honest about this a lot of
officers are self-serving a lot of
officers when they're cho they're given
a choice hey
do you want to have a paycheck for your
family or you want to not have a
paycheck for your family they're going
to make the decision that's going to
work out for them best
and this is why we have them doing
absurd things like dressing up
as undercover average civilians and they
and this is not the first time something
like this has happened there was
undercover officers dressing up as
homeless people
so they could get people for uh you know
eating yeah yeah
for giving money in some institutions
and in some places and also speeding
one last pushback humans in every
industry do things that hurt other
humans
it's not just the cops well we should
have made make people aware of that
because people are under this illusion
that they're there to protect and serve
get rid of their slogans
and say i am obeying my overlord that's
a more accurate statement here's here's
the simple way i'll break it down when
there are innocent people having their
businesses destroyed
who did nothing yes i think the police
do a good job when they stand up and
they defend
this the city and they try to maintain
order the best of their abilities
it's a very difficult position to be in
and that's why i say when antifa
is calling for defining the police while
burning everything down like y'all are
nuts
but then what happens when after you've
said thank you officially a good job he
says
shut your goddamn mouth and cracks you
in the mouth of truncheon and then
he personally throws the brick through
your window now i'm like bro you're
antifa
these cops going to a guy's business and
shutting it down that's exactly what
antifa was doing that i was complaining
about
the problem is when an individual
regardless of who they are where they
align destroy the livelihood of the
innocent
and the cops are doing that now so as
far as i'm concerned they're mud
in new york city sorry they're the same
thing as antifa was going around rioting
the cops are doing the same thing now
so who do we get the feds is trump gonna
send in somebody he should
he probably could but he's not gonna do
anything like that and he hasn't done
anything like that
and who else is gonna do it nobody so so
listen i wanna i wanna reference this
one more time
cuomo banned the sale of confederate
flags clearly in violation of the
constitution i don't confederate flag i
don't care for that stuff
but how are you going to be like that
constitution thing
screw off i don't care we're going to
pass the law
and then there's that viral video i
think it was out of california where you
had the it was a knicks greek i think it
was
and the health inspector the door was
open they're like your door is open so
that's all that matters you're getting a
fine
that's just the law sir and he goes what
law no law was ever passed
there was no vote there was nothing it
was just edict from some guy
we don't care sir these people are our
psychopaths and we are in serious
trouble because we're at a point now
where there's no cohesive culture
where people are like we are a nation of
laws and we abide by the constitution
we're now a nation of people being like
i don't know
just you know i was told to do it yep
and the bureaucrats that were enforcing
these laws that you were specifically
mentioning at that restaurant
were even screamed at by average
civilians walking by
saying why aren't you at costco why
aren't you at walmart
why are the big multinational
corporations allowed to exist
meanwhile small independent businesses
are getting squashed out
as these plutocrats are literally
obsessing about a great reset
and the redefinition of capitalism that
of course will empower them with even
more
authority more regulations more rules
and more bull crap that will only happen
because these officers
are deciding to choose to listen to
someone like andrew como and if they
decided to have a backbone some of them
are
there's a few sheriffs of new york that
decided and said no
and of course what did andrew como did
he what did he said he said that they're
dictators
because they're choosing not to follow
his own decrees and this is the person
by the way
that was also seriously accused of
abusing
a female counterpart which again a lot
of people in the mainstream media aren't
talking about especially cnn msnbc but
most importantly
joe biden is considering this man that
just
banned the the confederate flag like
like in new york we have so many
problems we have so many issues we have
to deal with but this man's main
objective is to ban
a symbol that no one really cares about
in new york anyway
that does nothing just virtual signal to
people how much of an
authoritarian he is this man might be
the next attorney general of the united
states
imagine the chaos the pain and suffering
that he will cause when he has more
power
underneath him and more willing servants
more obeyers
that of course will follow out every one
of his orders without even thinking
about it andrew cuomo
instructed sick coveted patients into
nursing homes killing about six thousand
meanwhile there was hospitals
all over new york city there was this
center was empty
we had a whole huge naval ship brought
in that was an
entire hospital central park field
hospitals and music
nothing and then sick elderly sent back
this is why i will say in my opinion the
only
explanation is that cuomo did it on
purpose
he was laughing and smiling and he said
we got covered patients
put them in the nursing homes but sir
the javits center is only at 30 capacity
i said put them in the nursing homes yes
sir i'll do whatever you say cause i'm a
bootlicker dude
the son of a gun won an emmy he won an
emmy
for his work regarding coke and then
wrote a book
and he wrote a book so congratulating
himself about
what a great job he did meanwhile he had
the highest death record than i think
anywhere else in the united states
yeah are you freaking kidding me and
this is going to be the next attorney
general
the united states who's the girl what do
you mean what do you mean by that's
that's number one he's that's the number
one candidate
is daddy because mario cuomo he's got
the name thanks for checking out this
clip from the tim cast
irl podcast we do the show live monday
through friday at 8pm so come back to
check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell
and we are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you